conference I want to begin by
congratulating you all
for years in election after election we
were told that Nicholas sturgeon would
be unstoppable
that it was a question of when not if
she would deliver Independence
times did we see newspaper headlines
saying that Scotland was on the cusp of
India F2
one particular paper tended to run that
story every other day
often it seemed like with the lone voice
of criticism the only party opposing her
demands for a second Independence
referendum the only
punching her handling of the pandemic
the only party standing up to her gender
reforms
we knew that her government and her
party shrouded in secrecy was not a
squeaky key clean as they liked to
portray
and we were criticized again and again
for going against the Hollywood
consensus who he prays on her
but no one is saying we're wrong now no
one is saying you're wrong
Nicola sturgeon's Legacy lies in tatters
her political career ended in failure
and all of you in this Hall and around
the country deserve credit for seeing
hero
[Applause]
as the Prime Minister said this morning
it was the Scottish conservative and
unionist party that stopped the SNP
winning a majority just two years ago
it was Scottish conservative and
universe msps that fought her dangerous
gender Reform Bill every step of the way
and it was our Scottish conservative
Secretary of State for Scotland my
friend Aleister Jack who stood up for
the rights of women and girls by sending
that flawed Bill back to the Scottish
government
Nicola surgeon kept seeing and talking
about wiping out the Tories yet because
of your hard work it's her that's gone
now without Nicholas surgeon that
deserves a round of applause
[Applause]
without Nicholas surgeon the s p have
entered into total meltdown but formerly
legendary discipline has evaporated the
unity has now totally broken down former
colleagues have become bitter Rivals the
parties ran out of cash the police have
arrested senior officials
to top it all off Hamza Yusuf has become
first minister
I can't think of a more obvious sign of
a party in crisis than that as key
Forbes so memorably said when he was
transport Minister the trains never ran
out of time when he was Justice Minister
the police were streamed to Breaking
Point and when he was Health Minister
there were record high waiting times
suffer that hey
her work for us
we've been seeing that for years now
clearly those in the SMP also agree
because the result of the SNP election
proved that
almost half of his own party didn't
think he was up to the job
during the leadership contest Hunter you
said proudly proclaimed himself as a
continuity candidate
comment that must come back to haunt him
now
but it's true as SNP leader he's
continued the same divisive approach as
his predecessor continuing to campaign
for Independence continuing to engineer
constitutional conflicts with the UK
government continuing to ignore the real
priorities of people across Scotland
in another one of his ill-advised
self-proclamations Hunter Youssef
declared himself the first activist
and that pretty much sums up his whole
approach to government
he's more interested in being the first
activist than first minister in
obsessing over splitting up communities
then appealing to the country in uniting
the SMP rather than uniting Scotland
in being a nationalist cheerleader than
a national leader
and he even appointed a minister for
Independence
a minister for Independence in his
government solely to drive forward the
snp's political obsession
that is taxpayers money
shamefully taking away from our public
services to pay the wages of a
nationalist campaigner
in yet another claim Hamza Yusuf said
that he would shift Independence into
fifth gear yet instead with this
famously uninsured driver at the wheel
the campaign is going into reverse the
camper van has stalled anifash Regan's
Independence thermometer was in
operation right now the Mercury would
have fallen out of the bottom
[Applause]
and of course the snp's financial
troubles have blown a huge hole in their
economic case for Independence
remember the s p said they wanted to
hold a referendum in just six months
time they can't even get an auditor in
the same same time frame they wanted to
set up a central bank when they wouldn't
even submit their own accounts they
would borrow billions of pounds from the
taxpayers here in Scotland to finance a
new country when they still owe tens of
thousands of pounds to Peter model and
just just for you Greg I've got to say
to our UK party chair I'm a bit
surprised that the police haven't found
a note from Nicholas saying there's no
money left
honestly if I if I
[Applause]
if I'd known this state the party was in
then I might have bet Nicola sturgeon a
lot more than 100 pounds that I would
Outlast there and I've got to see I'd
make the same date with Hamza Yusuf but
I'm not sure he can afford it
but seriously the SMP cannot even manage
their own accounts how can they be
trusted with the finances of an
independent Scotland
no one will ever believe a nationalist
again on currency on pensions or on
balancing the books
we've always known that our arguments on
trait currency and jobs were stronger
and the 2014 referendum proved that
now the SMP lack any credibility through
their own blunders the nationalists have
crashed the case for Independence
yeah incredibly despite all that's been
done Hamza Yusuf still won't put the
blame on his predecessor for the state
of his party
even with our ongoing police
investigation he is so indebted to his
Puppet Masters that you can't cut the
strings from Nicola and Peter model
the most powerful couple in the ruling
party of government were running the
show as a private affair
well together they have smashed to
Pieces any notion that the SMP are of a
higher standard than other parties and
because Hamza you can't bring himself to
cut the former leadership loose this
Scandal just continues to get worse and
worse
however we can't afford to be complacent
yes the SMP are down but they are not
out we need to work hard to seize the
opportunity we've been presented rather
than reveling in their misery
because the SMP are the party of
government
responsible for managing our Vital
public services and supporting our
economy
at a time when families across Scotland
are worried about the state of our
country
worried about whether they can make ends
meet worried about relatives stuck on an
NHS waiting list for months and years
worried about their job in a changing
economy this SMP government is too
distracted by their internal scandals
and their obsession with Independence to
focus on the big challenges Scotland
faces today
we saw that as clear as day in Hamza
yusu's attempt to relaunch last week
just 20 days into the job
we were boldly promised that he would
set out the priorities for his
government yet instead on the same day
we got a first Minister defending even
more Scandal when one of his own msps
was arrested by the police
for years we say that the s p were
unwilling to get on with the job but
they are now becoming increasingly
incapable of delivering the leadership
that Scotland needs
and all the while
all the while the real priorities of
Scottish people
are being ignored
the s p government aren't talking about
how we rebuild our health service from
the pandemic and Hamza uses
mismanagement
it's from our benches that people here
sandiskelhani standing up for his
Healthcare colleagues and patients
the SNP on talking about the state of
our economy and the Damage The Greens in
government are doing but people can see
Liz Smith competing for reach relief and
reform for Scottish businesses the
nationalists aren't talking about how 16
years of SMP government has devastated
Scottish education and let down a
generation of young people
so it's life to Stephen care to set out
our plans to restore Scottish
educational standards
right across Scotland people of all
political backgrounds right and left
unionist and nationalist are looking for
a party to focus on the issues and the
services that really matter to them
in Anna Sowers labor party they see a
party more interested in sound bites in
playing politics than standing up for
the views of the majority of Scots
remember he whipped his msps to back
Nicolas sturgeon and the S P's gender
Reform Bill and he supports Hamza Yusuf
legal challenge against the UK
government
no party focused on the real priorities
would support the nationalists in
pleading their constitutional games at
these challenging times
anasawar has given Hamza yusuf's
government a free pass to pursue their
political Obsession instead of opposing
as we do the SMP
of course with this he's not just
supporting the SMP he's opposing the
views of the majority of Scots on gender
recognition reform and even a majority
of Labor voters and in supporting the
SMP he's only helping to keep the
Scottish Parliament from focusing on the
issues that really matter to the
Scottish public
so it's up to us the score is
conservatives to be the only party that
voters can trust to always stand up to
the SMP government when they refuse to
prioritize on the issues that really
matter we are focused on the real
priorities of the Scottish people and we
offer them a vision of a better Scotland
with credible plans to deliver it into
the future
now we know
that one of the biggest issues of
concerns to them is rising household
bills
Vladimir Putin has been using Global
energy markets as a weapon in his
illegal war against Ukraine
driving up heating course for ordinary
families and endangering our supply
Rishi sunak and the UK government have
already taken decisive action to cap
bills to protect households from the
worst of these increases
but as a longer term fix we need to
ensure that we back Scotland's energy
sector to secure our supply
however under the influence of the green
Coalition Partners the SMP continue to
fail Scotland's oil and gas sector
ironically the former party of
Scotland's oil now wants to shut down
nor see production as soon as possible
putting at risk tens of thousands of
Scottish jobs
and Scottish labor backs that position
wholeheartedly
under my leadership the Scottish
conservatives will always stand up for
Northeast workers and the sectors that
employs them we will always put their
jobs first
[Applause]
through the hard work of our strong team
of Northeast MPS and msps and I'm
pleased to see there's too many of them
to actually name individually we are now
the only party standing up for
Scotland's oil but that doesn't mean
we're opposed to delivering Net Zero
because achieving our climate goals will
also help to cut bills for families
through reducing demand
the majority are Scottish families live
in housing that doesn't meet modern
Energy Efficiency standards
hundreds of thousands of households are
seeing hundreds of pounds of their money
seeping through old windows walls and
roofs every month
yet many cannot afford the thousands or
even tens of thousands of pounds
required to better insulate their homes
the s p government has plans for the
social rented sector
that homeowners shouldn't be forced to
help deliver a government Target without
government support
that's why Scottish conservatives would
introduce a help to renovate scheme this
would ensure that every Scottish
homeowner has access to Grants and loans
for Energy Efficiency improvements
and Net Zero must also be delivered with
Community consent and benefit at its
heart
yeah s p ministers have overturned local
planning objections in favor of wind
farm developments far too many times
that is a Hollywood power grab on our
communities I experienced it when I
chaired the planning committee at Murray
Council years ago and it continues today
at the same time communities receive
applicants in contributions from
developers and operators
those communities deserve to benefit
directly from local projects that we are
all reliant on for our energy security
so that's why I'm announcing today that
we will bring forward a community energy
benefit law this would ensure that those
communities not the SMP government have
the final say on energy developments in
their local area
and it would force developers and
operators to negotiate deals that make
meaningful Financial payments to
communities which could also be used to
directly cut energy bills
when I was in The Western Isles last
year and up in Shetland just a couple of
weeks ago that was an issue that was
raised and a request made by many the
Scottish conservatives have listened and
this proposal would not only create an
incentive to unblock the planning
barriers to energy infrastructure it
would also ensure that families and
communities always benefit directly from
those developments
ticking together
these plans that we are publishing today
in our policy paper will deliver lower
bills for Scottish families and ensure
that they have the final scene in
Scotland's Energy Future
now another big challenge that Scotland
is facing right now is the state of our
NHS we heard it in the session just
before now it's unbelievable that the
SMP Were Somehow so impressed by Hamza
uses running of the Health Service that
they decided to make them first minister
even he thought he'd done such a bad job
that he had to appoint a cabinet
secretary for NHS recovery and boy is it
needed the worst any waiting times in
history think about it the worst any
waiting times in history 53
000 patients stopped for more than half
a day last year and one in seven one in
seven on an NHS treatment list some
who've been waiting for years
are any chess is in crisis
for months Scottish conservatives
alongside Healthcare professionals have
said that the S P's flimsy recovery plan
is not cutting it
and we set out our own plans to help the
NHS cope with the worst of the winter
crisis
included allowing patients to see live
any waiting times expanding same day
operations and introducing maximum
waiting times yet this 10-yeared
Scottish SMP government ignored our plan
and the concerns of patients and
professionals
Scottish conservatives know that more
than anything else Scott's just won an
NHS that is there for them and their
loved ones when they need it most
we know that one of the areas under
threat is the future of local GP
services
yeah the SMP are still failing to
deliver their funding promises to
general practice
the remote and Rural general practice
working group delivered their
recommendations in January 2020 to
ensure that GP surgeries helped that
funding and staff they need to continue
but those recommendations have been
Gathering dust on a shelf rather than
being implemented so Scottish
conservatives would Implement those
plans as a matter of urgency to save our
surgeries not just in rural areas but
right across the country
and we also need to focus on the
substantial health challenges that we
all know Scotland faces
we're holding our confidence in the
Fantastic city of Glasgow
in 2021 the last year that figures are
available
311 class regions died because of drug
misuse
the highest number anywhere in the
country
if we won a life that could have been
saved and a family Mourning
a loved one who was filled by A system
that didn't work for them
for years Nicholas sturgeon's eye was
off the ball and it's even tons of Yusuf
will be no different
we are lifting some of the most
vulnerable people in Scotland die by not
giving them access to the treatment
options that they deserve
that's why we are in this party
continuing the work to pass the right to
recovery bill that would give Scott's
legal access to the addiction recovery
treatment that they need
yet we need to go further in tackling
the public health killers that light our
country
for example a recent public health
Scotland report found that over the last
decade suicide was the biggest killer of
young people in our country
sadly that is the experience of 753
families in Scotland last year
we need to do more
that's why we would rule out mental
health ambulances to ensure there's a
dedicated response for mental health
emergencies
and we would give Mental Health crisis
centers the funding they don't yet get
but absolutely deserve
we tackle the big public health
challenges facing Scotland we also save
our NHS resources in the long term and
put the Relentless decline in standards
into the reverse
that's what we can achieve with our
government that is focused on the task
of leading our Health Service instead of
one that's content to manage its decline
well its attention is distracted
elsewhere
rdnhs is Scotland's most treasured
institution it needs a government that
gives it the focus it absolutely
deserves
and
and speaking of top priorities I'm long
enough in the truth to remember the SMP
government saying that education was
their number one priority it never was
under Nicholas sturgeon and I'm really
wondering if it ever will be under Hamza
Yusuf because when I was growing up our
Scottish education system was the Envy
of the world yeah over the last 16 years
our schools have fallen to record lows
in International League tables and
Nicola sturgeon completely failed
completely filled in her goal of closing
the attainment gap
the next generation of Scots my kids and
yours are being left pooter because of
the actions of the SMP government
that for me is the greatest failure of
their time in office
when I look at my TV boys Alice said and
James and they're not fighting with each
other or playing with the chickens and
the goats I know that one of the biggest
reasons I'm in politics is to deliver
better opportunities for them and
children like them up and down the
country
what kind of society are we if we don't
prioritize that
my own parents my mama School cook my
dad a family Burger didn't have much but
they worked hard to give me and my
sisters the best possible star in life
we in this party know that a good
education is the best way to deliver no
matter where people come from or their
background
so even in these times or stretch
resources we must prioritize restoring
Scotland's education for the Next
Generation
that means giving teachers a support and
even more importantly the trust
firstly we need to attract good teachers
to come to the profession and crucially
stay in it
teachers are burnt out
feel like this SMP government is asking
more of them but not upholding their end
of the bargain by tackling issues that
make their job more difficult
that's why the Scottish conservatives
discussed plans this morning on a new
deal for teachers
our deal would cut down on paperwork
give teachers more time to prepare
quality lessons and reward them for
extra classes and after school teaching
should incentivize teachers to go above
and beyond and to help every pupil
achieve their potential
we'd also increase the powers of head
teachers to take decisions over the
running and priorities of their school
and improve the teaching of essential
life skills
so that we're ensuring that teaching is
more aligned to the needs of pupils
rather than the national targets set in
Hollywood
taken together with our exciting plans
for a national tutoring and mentoring
service increased subject choice and
improved stem teaching the Scottish
conservatives have a plan to restore
Scottish education
thank you
where the SMP have failed we would meet
given the Next Generation the best start
in life our number one priority they
said they would do it they didn't we
said we would do it we will deliver but
we know we know that learning and skills
development can't just be for children
and young people
as our economy changes people will have
to change careers
yet in Scotland we don't do anywhere
near enough to support those workers
some of the most dynamic economies in
the world have a strong support system
for adult learning and re-skilling
it needs to be at the core of how we
tackle the fourth Industrial Revolution
and the productivity challenge
that's why the Scottish conservatives
have proposed secretion of a national
college
and why we would give every Scott a
right to retrain through use it or lose
its skills funding
so that wherever people live and
whatever their ability they can access
high quality education for training and
upskilling and so that we can deliver
the growth today and in the future
now we heard the Elliot and his remarks
on the stage and his answers to
questions just how passionate our prime
minister Rishi sunak and the UK
government are to see Scotland's economy
Thrive and grow
but SMP and their green Partners see
growth as an evil they believe that
wealth and business and Enterprise are
dirty words
supporting businesses for them means
hiking taxes and introducing a botched
deposit return scheme
Lorna Slater was humiliatingly forced to
delete
now you would hope that the most
knowledgeable voice in Parliament on
this issue would have been the
ministered in charge but it wasn't again
it came from our benches Morris golden
has been all over this issue and the
detail on it warning the government for
months about the problems they were
creating
through his persistent campaigning we
now have a delay to this scheme that it
needs an overhaul if it's actually going
to work
the Scottish government is clearly
anti-business that we in the Scottish
conservatives are unashamably
pro-business pro-growth and pro worker
we were the only party
[Applause]
we were the only party holding the
government to account over its low
payment of Grants and lifting of
restrictions in the pandemic we were the
only party challenging the anti-business
policies like the rent freeze and
short-term leg controls and we are the
only party up Wards to raising taxes on
1.4 million Scottish workers for the
other parties pretend to be false
Friends of the business Community it is
the Scottish conservatives that actually
stand up for their interests for people
of all political backgrounds who believe
in a competitive Dynamic Scottish
economy this party this Scottish
conservatives is your natural home
[Applause]
yet it's it's not just economic growth
that the s p and the greens have put at
risk but Rural and Coastal livelihoods
too
Hamza yusuf's government propped up by
the wine bar revolutionaries Patrick
Harvey and Lauren Slater is intent on
making it harder for Farmers to farm and
fishermen to fish
as someone who studied at an
agricultural college and represents so
many coastal areas those sectors and
communities will always be at the heart
of this party's agenda
one issue that they face is rural theft
which costs are farmers millions of
pounds every single year that's why I
can announce it Rachel Hamilton will
bring forward a bill in the Scottish
Parliament to better protect farm
equipment from being stolen and sold on
we'll also deliver a rural development
Bank to invest in rural projects and
businesses and change procurement rules
to ensure that public bodies like
schools use good local food so that the
Scottish public sector backs Scottish
farmers
and for Scotland's Coastal communities
we will oppose the blank introduction of
Highly protected Marine areas every step
of the way
[Applause]
under my leadership the Scottish
conservatives will always be the
champion of rural Scotland and our food
producers
thank you
now another area in which the Scottish
conservatives are challenging the
Hollywood consensus and representing the
majority of Scots is Justice again we
heard in the panel session this morning
so many important issues coming up and
we know that the SMP of watered-down
sentencing so far
the even Reap is no longer considered an
automatic deal sentence
let that sink in in Scotland we are
giving Community sentences to reap us
this SNP government is attacking women
safe spaces and protections through the
gender Reform Bill while also taking a
soft stance on the main who commit
horrendous crimes
on Justice comes a useless government
has all the wrong priorities and values
the rights and protections of criminals
are being put above victims whose lies
have been devastated
the Scottish conservatives are the only
party demanding a wholesale change in
how Justice is delivered in Scotland and
backing our police to tackle crime we
want to see whole life sentences
introduced for the worst crimes and at
this conference we've set out plans to
toughen up Community p-back orders and
through Jamie Green's victims bill we
have a plan to put victims first in our
justice system something that has been
ignored by so long so while the other
parties all support a soft touch
approach to Justice the Scottish
conservatives are the only party who
believe that crime should be properly
punished by the law
and one subscribe
[Applause]
one such crime not being properly
tackled is spiking
imagine going for a drink at the local
pub and vomiting and passing out after
just a single drink
well that's the experience of one in ten
women across the United Kingdom
in the last year that we have figures
for there were
444 incidents reported
police Scotland
spiking is a significant risk to both
women and men across Scotland and that's
why I thought it was absolutely right
and I was delighted to see my colleague
Russell Finley announce on STV last
night Scottish conservative plans to
tackle this awful crime his bill would
ensure that testing kits and trained
staff are available at premises as a
condition of their licensing this would
mean that anyone who suspects that their
drink has been spite can get it
immediately tested and shooting that the
victim is protected and there's a
significantly higher chance of catching
the culprit and we tackle the scourge of
spiking
now
throughout this conference we've already
heard it today we'll hear more tomorrow
we are bringing forward the policies
that matter to people across Scotland
our community benefit law to help
re-renovate its team to cut family bills
protecting GPS and delivering better
Mental Health Emergency Response
offering teachers a new deal to restore
Scotland's education system for the Next
Generation investing in a right to
retrain to build the skills we need to
grow Scotland's economy and create good
jobs tackling spiking and toughening up
Community sentencing to put our justice
system on the side of the victims those
are just some of the policies we are
taking forward to tackle the real
priorities of the Scottish people
but it's not just about policies we will
continue to hold the s p government to
account we will represent the views of
the majority of our country who feel
that the Hollywood consensus doesn't
speak for them
and we will take forward our own
positive ideas and solutions to show
that the Scottish conservatives
have an optimistic and ambitious vision
for our country's future
this feeling SMP government mired in
Scandal and sleaze cannot focus on
governing our country they cannot tackle
the big challenges Scotland is facing
and it's painfully obvious that Hamza
Yusuf is not up to the job of being
first minister
[Applause]
at the general election next year people
across Scotland have a choice they can
give Hamza Yusuf a blank check the
thumbs up to continue to lead an
incompetent government and to focus on
the priorities or of the SMP or they can
unseat SMP MPS and their referendum
Obsession and send a strong signal to
Hamza yusuf's government to focus on the
real priorities of Scotland and the best
way to do that in seats the length and
breadth of Scotland is to support the
Scottish conservatives
thank you
[Applause]
we've made a strong start at this
conference but this can only be the
beginning
of our mission
we need to re-earn the trust of people
who've supported us in the past and
reach out to people who've never
considered us before
the vast majority of schools of all
political backgrounds are just looking
for a party to focus on the bread and
butter issues that matter to them we
need to be that party
as a Nicholas sturgeon era of Scottish
politics comes crashing down we enter a
new chapter in our nation's history the
SNP are losing the trust of the Scottish
people but no party has yet filled that
vacuum all bets are up Scotland stands
at a crossroad
if we want the country to take a fresh
look at our party then we need to offer
a positive Vision that Scotland needs we
need to be the party of all of Scotland
focused on improving the lives of people
up and down the country we need to rise
above the partisan interests to tackle
the big challenges we all face and show
the people of Scotland in every
Community across our country that the
Scottish conservatives are the ones who
are focused on Scotland's real
priorities thank you very much
thank you